okay hey how are ya here they are he is
the editor-in-chief of Reason magazine
Matt Welch hey Matt great to have you
back here ah she's a Democratic
strategist and CEO of impact strategies
Angela Wray welcome to our show and he's
a staff writer for The New Yorker Adam
Gopnik
read all the time always enjoy it Adam
all right remember to follow me on
facebook twitter and instagram and send
us your questions for tonight's overtime
so we can answer them after the show on
YouTube okay so I think the word of the
week was politicized I heard it a lot we
certainly heard it yesterday from the
president talking about guns but I think
it was also relevant the Planned
Parenthood meetings that were hearings
that were going on in Congress and also
I think the Benghazi hearings might be a
little political but let's start with
the guns and then throw it all on the
table together
I heard the president say two things
I've never heard a president say first
he said we should politicize this issue
he said this is a political choice we
make to allow this to happen every
couple of months and then he said
prayers are not enough Wow a president
saying prayers are not enough
it was a brave thing and she's been
awhile getting there I think the reason
that the president said that bill is
exactly because this is one of those
problems where we know the solution we
see those parents grieve we see those
kids dying we read about cell phones
ringing still in the pockets of dead
kids because their parents is still
trying to reach them because they've
heard about the shooting and we know
what to do about it we know it was huge
body of social science and research that
gun control works on gun violence as
effectively as antibiotics work on
bacterial infections if we had done laws
like the gun I don't know about that
which is to say not perfectly but
overwhelmingly and almost all of the
overwhelmingly yes well Nathan this
rotary way this shooter yesterday didn't
have assault weapons he didn't have any
weapon that the Democrats want to outlaw
yes any 70s any background check that
you can imagine he liked most mass
shooters would they they pass background
checks because they generally haven't
committed crimes in the past Matt it's
exactly like saying you see we give we
give sick kids aspirin and they don't
get better
that proves medicine doesn't work what
we do know from the experience of Canada
what we know from the experience of
Australia where they had a horrific mass
shooting and then they cut down they
brought in really stringent and
effective gun control laws and there
hasn't been this yeah yeah but that's a
duty yeah but that's not what even the
Liberals are talking about in this
country doing what they did correct
Elliott that's the difference is that
they're still not getting at the root of
the problem the Second Amendment well
like an amendment the Second Amendment I
don't think is a is a root problem you
have to remember really yes you have to
remember bill that the interpretation
the radical miss reading of the Second
Amendment that we live under now which
says the Second Amendment guarantees
rights to individuals to own guns is
extremely recent it only took up up
seven years ago in Scalia's Heller
decision before that for almost 200
years the consensus the consensus of
constitutional scholars on all sides and
of the Supreme Court was that the Second
Amendment which after all begins talking
about a well-regulated militia reference
a well-regulated militia that had only
protected the rights of the states to
form militias now
you may disagree with that but that was
the consensus view until seven short
years ago and all we need to do is to
have the sanity or that you know that's
dying of gun violence no no one was
dying with the same regularity of gun
massacres as they are today
so let me just chime in here I think the
first thing we have to acknowledge is
that there have been almost a thousand
mass shooting deaths since Sandy Hook
and that's December 2012 we have a major
problem on our hands and so what we need
to think about is what the president
means by politicizing this this is it a
partisan exercise to politicize
something in the terms that he's using
it it is to ensure that we're using the
public policy veins of Congress of
executive orders to make something
happen we cannot afford to do that any
more people are dying
he even challenged the press yesterday
to compare what's happened in terms of
terrorist attacks and deaths by
terrorist attacks versus gun violence in
this country
gun violence was overwhelmingly the
people that's what I thought was
different you don't often hear a
politician in America say hey it's back
on you people politicians say the people
are perfect if only we could live up to
their standard blahblah yadda-yadda
he was like you know I
can't do this all alone right
he actually said you have to be a
one-issue candidate on gun control
that's even too far for me Michael
Bloomberg tried that this past election
cycle he created a group that was going
to fund single issue candidates on this
and they pretty much failed across the
board Michael Bloomberg big gun
controller let's remember what what
applied gun control looks like stop and
frisk was an anti gun program it was
that was the goal of it is to disarm
people in poor communities in the
federal system you are if you are in the
federal system for a gun crime 47% of
them are black these are things that you
have to think about when you're giving
police red power to your point about
sort of what magic wand we can waive to
make this better the the actual policy
on the table is usually in the wake of
these shootings is let's expand
background checks that's the only thing
they can get Pat okay but let's talk
about they can't even get that but let's
talk about that policy of background
checks there are two problems with it
what is like there's two problems are
the one is that the mass shooters will
pass
Grunk checks which we talked about
before but the second problem is a Bill
Maher problem which is to say if we
suddenly expand we have a lot of Bill
Maher problems if we suddenly miss doner
I never shot anybody that's a problem
that's a problem yes because because
every single federal background check
says you can't have a gun if you have
used a controlled substance well I could
have to get my gun up that exactly no
that's the thing what you're going to do
is you're going to disenfranchise people
on purpose from Second Amendment rights
of owning a gun if you have been a farm
worker if I have committed a non-violent
family felony and if you've smoked pot
let me know that one more thing before
we move on from guns which is that I
hear all the time when these things
happen it's a mental health issue and of
course they talking they're talking
about individuals and of course any
individual who does this is mentally ill
they don't seem to ever talk about the
collective mental aberration that every
country every nation has some poor
irrationality that it seems unable to
escape what you're saying that is
basically it's a counsel of despair
these kids are going to continue to die
we're going to continue to see these
regular massacres because well what are
we going to do about it the overriding
reality is is that we have this
irrational fixation on guns we have
rightt and a love of God love them and I
want to show you this this street sign I
saw a couple of years ago it was in the
news I grew up not far from Wayne New
Jersey it says warning if you hit one of
these kids because you are speeding you
will not need a lawyer picture of a gun
that's the problem right there that's
the American mindset guns are awesome
they fix all problems just like in
movies like guns are this incredibly
potent symbol of autonomy for a lot of
Americans and I understand that the
problem is it's not an effective form of
autonomy because the one thing we know
is that possession of a gun makes it
much more likely you're going to kill
someone in your family than you're ever
going to confront an intruder or a bad
guy it's all existing around the family
you